The emoluments clause, violations of the a
to the constitution continued to just rack
up seemingly day after day.
There are new violations to the emoluments
clause of the constitution by Donald Trump
and the people around him. This time vice
president Mike Pence in Ireland is staying
at Donald Trump's golf resort despite the
reality that the golf resort is on the opposite
side of Ireland, completely inconveniently
located for the Dublin meetings and events
that Mike Pence has. So what's the solution?
Pence is going to stay at Trump's golf resort,
play golf there as he did over the weekend
and fly back and forth across the country,
which is a three hour drive each way so that
he can continue to enrich Trump and Trump's
family by staying at his resort, even though
it makes no sense on the screen. If you're
watching along with us, you will see a map
of Ireland. You will see that Dublin where
pence has events is the opposite side of the
country as Dune Beg, which is where Donald
Trump's golf course and hotel are.
You will also notice on this second nap that
there are endless hotels available in double
at Dublin. And yes, I don't expect my capacity
to stay at a two star hotel, but there are
plenty of Nice hotels available in Dublin,
right where Mike Pence could have stayed in
order to be able to walk to his meetings.
I'm sure he would still get a ride, but none
of those are Trump hotels. So Mike Pence is
going to fly across the country on your dollar,
on taxpayer dollars, playing golf at Donald
Trump's property in Ireland, continuing to
enrich Trump, one of the most profitable profitable
presidencies in history by staying at Donald
Trump's hotels. Now, Donald Trump likes to
say being president has cost him. Maybe he
has, he said billions. I know he said millions
and millions. I guess the argument is by focusing
on making America great again, he's not focusing
on his businesses and there are opportunity
costs and whatever else.
And this is extremely, uh, uh, damaging to
his personal finances. Of course. The truth
is the opposite, that Donald Trump has been
funneling untold numbers of dollars into his
business businesses, which he and his family
reap the profits from helicopters security
will be necessary for Mike Pence going back
and forth, back and forth from Trump's resort
over to Dublin, making everything take way
longer than it otherwise has to inconveniencing
way more people than it would normally have
to. Also, Mike Pence can continue the grift
and keep funneling government money. This
is your tax money. The money that conservative
say they know what to do with far better than
the government knows what to do with. It's
getting funneled into Donald Trump's pocket
into don junior's pocket into Eric Trump and
Ivanka Trump. I don't know if to Trump doesn't
seem to like Tiffany Trump, but maybe she
gets some of the money as well.
I thought that the right was against wasteful
spending of their tax dollars. What is more
useless than this? What's I mean truly there
is no limit to Donald Trump's greed. This
is the height of the kleptocracy and he is
getting away with it. Mike Pence, chief of
staff. Mark Short said that the decision said
earlier today that the decision to stay at
Trump international golf links in dune bag
was made at Donald Trump's suggestion that
I actually believe we talk about how anytime
Trump says anything, anytime a Trump lackey
says anything we have to trust but verify
or maybe not even trust, but just try to verify
because they lie all the time about everything.
The idea that Trump suggested, hey Mike, you
go into Ireland. You should stay at my resort.
That is believable. We should still try to
fact check it, but that one I actually believe,
and Mike Pence just loves it.
Trump is getting kickbacks from pence in a
sense to show just how loyal Mike Pence is
to Donald Trump. And speaking of which, let's
not put all the attention on Mike Pence because
Donald Trump's dirty attorney general William
Barr is going to be hosting a Christmas party
for a couple of hundred people, I believe
in early December, where other than Donald
Trump's Washington d c hotel, and there's
actually something hilarious in this one.
We're being told by the Justice Department
that the only hotel that was available for
William Bar's Christmas party was Trump's
hotel in Washington d c if that's true. That's
actually kind of funny because it means people
already booked every other hotel. Nobody wanted
Trump's hotel and that was therefore the only
one left. It doesn't exactly make it seem
like the elite destination that Donald Trump
Trump claims it to be, but in any case, they
are all doing it. They are all enriching Donald
Trump and his family.
The swamp was filled with a fire hose under
this presidency. The extraordinary corruption
of this administration is going unchecked
and the, I don't even have the delusion that
there may be consequences to any of this stuff.
This, it's going unchecked. Period. Removal
of Donald Trump from the White House is the
only way to do it, and I'm already getting
these lame flacid right-wingers, figuratively
speaking, of course, who write in and say
Bernie would be the same. Bernie's got his
three houses and he owns stock and he would
benefit from a good economy. Does anybody
understand the difference between Bernie writing
a book about his political career and making
enough money to get vacation homes, uh, with
a net worth of about 1.1 or one point $2 million,
which at nearly age 80 is actually not that
much. I understand he's still way more privileged
than tens of millions of Americans, but in
the grand scheme of things have being nearly
80 and having a net worth of one point $2
million is not.
The problem that we have in this country and
Trump is, are equating that to a literal grifter
president who is running a presidency for
profit and just stuffing government money.
Your money, which supposedly you cared about
and didn't want going anywhere that was wasteful
into his own pockets, in the pockets of his
family. Get it. You can't even talk to these
people. If anyone thinks that Bernie making
money off of a book is in any way comparable
to what Donald Trump is doing, you're living
on such a different planet that we probably
are not going to understand each other. And
I would suggest not even trying to talk to
those people. Make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman
show. And while you're there, follow me on
Instagram at David Dot. Pacman major, major
developments,
uh, in the world of my tomato plants, which
are now flourishing with orange and red tomatoes.
I will try to post an update to my Instagram
page later for that.